Okay, yeah, so we can get started. So
today, um I guess the lecture will be in
two parts. The first part, I will just
be talking about some like
basics, foundational stuff in video
generation, or like kind of the past,
like history of like the last two
three plus years of what's been going on
in the area. Uh and then in the latter
half uh Bill and Tim will come and talk
about some of the stuff they're doing at
OpenAI with Sora.
Cool.
So, brief outline, some basics,
some general things of how you can
improve like future work of video
generation, and then and then more
applications around like using like a a
video generation model as a simulator,
and also potentially using it for video
editing, which are probably the two main
applications of these models uh that are
most relevant today, and the reason why
people are potentially like interested
in this area at all.
So,
I guess to start off, like training on
video itself as a modality is actually
quite different uh than a lot of other
modalities. I guess the other ones
primarily being like language, and the
other one being images.
And one of the
most annoying things about working with
videos is that it's super
it's like really large. There's like a
lot of numbers.
Um
to get it to put into perspective, so a
lot of videos that we view online from
YouTube or that we stream are encoded
using standard codecs like H.264, 265,
AV1, depending on uh what site you're
streaming it from, uh and how recent or
old the video is.
Um but in terms of file sizes, so if you
have like 1-minute encoding of like HD
1080p like 24 FPS video,
which is kind of like what Sora is
generating um in the end, it's roughly
like 20 megabytes
plus or minus. Depends on the actual
content of your video, but it's like
somewhere on that order. Um and then
during training, what we usually do,
whether like if you want to train on
images or you want to train on on video,
you would uncompress that video, you
would store as just like uh
raw raw byte tensor of like your your
pixels like 1920 by 1080. Um
and then like the number of time steps,
which would in this case would be like
FPS * seconds, so you have
So, if you want to do 1 minute of video
like I guess this would be 60 FPS. If
you If you have a 1 minute video at 60
FPS,
um
then you have 3600 frames, and then you
you have three extra numbers for RGB.
Um the number 8 gigs is actually for 24
FPS. I just forgot to edit the FPS from
60 to 24. Um but in total your your
tensor if you stored it would be a would
be roughly 8 gigabytes.
Um and then usually what you do is you
also standardize it, so you divide by
255, and then move it to a minus one
one, and that would be from
U and 8 to a float 32. So, you would
then have
uh
So, then it'll basically be even more
expensive
to to store this data because now each
Now each number is represented by a
float, which is 4 bytes instead of
instead of 1 byte before. So, that video
itself is only worth like around 32
gigs, which is
uh
really big. It's like if you had one
A100, you can probably fit You You can
at least fit it on the GPU. Mu- Much
less if you actually wanted to train it,
it'd be uh train on that data, it'd be a
lot trickier.
Okay.
So, I guess to get some intuition of why
like these things get compressed cuz
this is like a really big factor.
Depending on the video, it could be like
50 to like a thousand X compression from
like the original file size.
Um
or at least the original like
representation in which you're training
in.
So, the way that some of these video
codecs generally work, at least this is
for like one specific kind. I'm not sure
about exactly others, but they all kind
of do similar things.
Just sometimes in like smarter ways than
others.
Um
but the way these videos are encoded,
they're
generally encoded to three different
kinds of frames. So, it's like frame by
frame.
So, you have I-frames, which is also
known as key frames, which these they
encode like they just basically treat
that frame as an image and then they
just encode that full frame, maybe using
standard techniques like something very
similar to JPEG. Um
and then they have something called P
and B frames, which are predicted and
bidirectional frames, which essentially
they don't encode the raw the entire
frame, they encode the frame conditioned
on like some sort of like surrounding uh
key frames or or even prior P or B
frames.
Um and these are
and they usually encode some sort of
like relative. So, it's like they encode
like motion of certain blocks rather
than the entire pixels.
And the way these are generally done is
the relative encoding is kind of like
you can imagine
uh they use like motion estimation, so
they store motion vectors of like uh 16
by 16 blocks in in your videos. So,
this is like a a frame from like a
certain video and then the red arrows
that you can see are basically what the
the motion vectors that are computed as.
Um which you can kind of infer like
without even seeing the video, you can
kind of guess like where the motion in
the video is happening because there's
nothing really happening in like the
surrounding scenery, that's kind of like
static. So, it's probably the the big
rabbit doing something. It's probably
mo- moving his arm up a little bit
because there's more motion on his arms
and maybe tilting his body a little bit.
Um
to that. But, the important thing is
that this representation is like very
sparse. So, it's So, this is kind of how
the compression is kind of achieved in
the sense that you're not storing like
the entire
uh pixels or all the pixels or even in a
compressed format, you're storing it
relative or basically how much you're
storing this frame as like a delta to
like a prior frame or even a prior delta
of like a key frame and and and much
stuff has changed.
The one important thing is that they're
able to also achieve really high
compression is because these encodings
are also fundamentally lossy.
Um for like MPEG's or like for certain
codex you can basically choose how how
lossy do I want the encoding to be. It's
kind of like essentially like JPEG for
in for images or for for videos. Um
but even with like pretty high like with
the video at like 20 meg's
or like 100 or 500 x compression you can
still get like really good like visual
quality of your videos.
So
one way to think about how these
standard codex So these are like after
like people like you know they use very
basic
methods in like machine learning of like
like like optimization stuff like that
that is like
generally very fast like very separate
very different from like the AI stuff we
do today. You know this stuff you can
run on your CPU you can stream it live
as you watch a video.
Um so generally these algorithms are
very fast but also they're surprisingly
efficient.
Um
and one way to think about these is the
I-frames um so I guess for videos if you
want to compress videos there's two
things. There's like spatial redundancy
which if you just treated each frame as
an image you can compress the image. Um
and there's also temporal redundancy
which is probably the more relevant one
here. Like imagine if you had a video at
60 FPS then like one frame to the next
frame will have very very little change.
Like the arm could move up like two
pixels or something or the scene can
shift like a few pixels. It's like when
you have that high of a frame rate like
there's a lot of redundancy that you can
leverage to encode things
uh more efficiently.
So essentially a lot of works
in the past few years on video
generation is
is like we we we kind of have all of
like the the tools that we need. So so
it let's say we like video is a very
complex distribution we kind of know how
to do that. We have like auto regressive
models we have diffusion models we know
those can model highly complex data.
Uh we have architectures whether it's
like units or transformers. Like units
borrowed from images. Um, transformers
have been pretty successful in like
pretty much all modalities.
And
so so theoretically we can just like use
all these techniques,
train it on video and have a really good
video model.
So, the question here is like what
exactly is the bottleneck? And the main
thing is just kind of what I've been
talking about is like
this video data is is very like
it's very compute heavy.
If we just ported all of our existing
methods in a naive way, it it'd be
really hard to generate like
really long high fidelity
video because there's just like so many
frames you have to process and there's
just so many like numbers that you need
to process to to model the distribution.
So, a lot of the work has been focused
around building and designing more
efficient models. And this can take in a
lot of different forms, which I'll kind
of go over like the general paradigms.
Um,
and they're not exactly mutually
exclusive. There's some overlap, so you
can like mix and match certain things.
Um,
but I'll go over some like
broad ways that people approach it.
And also the relevant papers. So, the
the first one
is essentially if in the end let's say
for Imagine Video they generated like 24
FPS like
uh, like 1080 by 768 or or something
like that
uh,
video um,
and one way you can do it in a very
naive way, you can just uh, take your
unit, take like your full resolution
full frame video, train that. It's just
uh, extremely expensive and they didn't
have the compute really to actually do
that directly or you would be limited to
like a very small model and you wouldn't
really be able to model anything
complex.
So, what they did was for a lot of these
papers, Imagine Video, Make-A-Video,
Pai Paiocco and uh,
Lumiere, kind of
really listen it out from like
2 years ago up to like close to the
present day
uh is they break up the problem into a
smaller independent pieces. This is
There will be some overlap with some of
the stuff that I covered in the
diffusion lecture.
Uh
with consisting of like
instead of directly generating full
resolution video, you you generate maybe
a smaller resolution video, and then you
you upsample it over space, upsample it
over time, and maybe you can upsample it
over space and time, but like a series
of many different models that will do
this.
So, we had this
same figure a while back um of how they
imagine video is, where they have their
text prompt. Uh they encode it using the
T5 XXL for language embeddings. And then
for generation, they
do a step-by-step. They have their
really low resolution video, so 40 by 20
specially with 16 frames. And this
represents I think like
like 10 seconds of video, if I remember
correctly. Or
or maybe not. This is this is 120 frames
at 24 FPS.
So, maybe like 5
seconds.
Um
Oh, it's at 3 FPS, yeah.
Um and then they go through temporal
super resolution to
expand in time, spatial super
resolution, spatial super resolution,
temporal, temporal.
This is a a lot of different models. You
don't have to do this many. Maybe you
just do one step of spatial super
resolution, one step of temporal.
Um
but I think at the time with like their
compute budgets, they were fairly like
they had to partition their model into
more steps of training. Um
and the one nice thing is now at this
point that you can you can train each
model individually and independently.
So,
if you only have a budget of like a
thousand TPUs or something, then you can
train uh
each like then then each model would
only need to fit that amount of compute
versus if you try to do an entire
pipeline, you you'll need more compute
to fit the entire model.
Yeah.
Um this is some examples of videos.
So, this is what the state of it was
like two two years ago.
Year and a half, maybe. Um,
and you guys will slowly see how like
progress has been kind of made.
Uh, the biggest jump is probably Sora,
which I think Tim and Bill will have a
lot of examples there.
Um, imagine video of like a of a teddy
bear walking or running down the street.
I think that's on the right is like a
pan over Yosemite, I think.
Um,
and this is a more recent one called
Lumiere. I think they had this was like
in January.
Um,
this was all all still
even for these models all still fairly
limited short videos.
So,
this was 80 frames 16 FPS, so 5-second
video. They generated uh, so this one
has no temporal super resolution, so
they directly generate all the frames
just at a low spatial resolution. So, 80
by 128 by 128, and then they have a
separate super resolution process that
upsamples directly 128 to to 1024.
Um,
so so this is like one other option to
break down the problem
in terms of how they approached it. But,
still a similar approach. So, this is
like less pieces than uh imagine video,
um, but
still like a very similar architecture.
Yes. Uh, for that temporal super
resolution, do they train it basically
by just like cutting out frames and then
like making them
For imagine video? Uh,
yes. Um,
that I'm not sure, but
Uh, so what what it could have been done
is, um, they just directly like if you
use FFmpeg to process the 24 FPS video
to 3 FPS or something,
and the way FFmpeg does it I'm actually
not entirely sure.
Um, it could do some combination of like
cutting the of like slice of like
selecting certain frames in in doing
like uh some sort of interpolation. But
yeah, I'm not sure about the exact
algorithm. So on a high level it goes
from like predicts from low FPS to
expands to high FPS. Mhm.
Yeah.
Uh these are some examples from Lumiere.
So definitely more consistent now in
terms of uh
like the the bear is a little bit more
coherent. Um smoother textures, stuff
like that.
Okay, and
an- another way that um so so that was
kind of like the cascaded approach where
uh you you break it up into small pieces
and you slowly apply super resolution in
various dimensions until you get your
final result.
Um
the the other main method,
which this is not really mutually
exclusive with the super resolution.
With all these models you can always
kind of do super resolution, but uh
ideally there's just a need to like have
as few models in your pipeline as
possible so it's not that complicated
and it's easier to scale. If you have
like seven models in your pipeline and
you want to train like a 10x larger
model, you have to then figure out what
part do I actually scale, how much do I
scale it? It's a little bit more
complicated. Um if you have only like
one or two models it's like a lot easier
to manage.
And also in terms of like writing code
for for this kind of stuff.
Um
so the the other predominant approach
that has been pretty popular is just the
uh
I guess what I call like a per-frame
latent space models. This is mostly
motivated by the fact that like like
Stability had their Stable Diffusion
model. So so a lot of it was like, "Oh,
we have a really really good text to
image model. Now,
if you want to train on video, how how
can I use this text to image model?
Doesn't exactly fit, but like it it
could be useful suddenly because if you
if it boils down to like a like a a
video generation problem, the first
frame is like a kind of like a text to
image generation problem, essentially.
So, they're all very related.
And uh the way this approach is done is
you can basically, let's say you can use
your standard your your pre-trained VAE
from stable diffusion. So, that's a
that's an image encoder, and you can
take your video, and then you can
leverage spatial compression, and you
can compress each frame of your video.
So, now you have some sort of latent for
every frame of your video.
And then the kind of
naive way, if you want to temporally
compress, because like if you directly
try to
train on like 24 FPS with this, you'd
have to stack like even for like 4
seconds of video, you'd have to stack
like 96 frames uh or concatenate them,
which is pretty expensive.
Um so, what these papers usually do is
it's like kind of like a very
simple way of doing temporal compression
is you just lower the frame rate.
So, it's like a it's like
it is very lossy, but it actually works
decently well. So,
let's say it's very similar in spirit to
the the the the the like super
resolution or the FPS like resolution
uh where you basically just sample like
you can concatenate per frame, but you
sample your video at a low frame rate.
Four frames per second
is like pretty standard. And then after
that, you could learn a separate frame
interpolation model to to upsample the
frame rate.
So, in this case, there usually is not a
uh spatial super resolution model, and
it's only something over time.
Um these are a few a few papers that uh
if you're ever interested, Align Your
Latents,
Emu Video, Stable Video Diffusion, they
all use like a similar approach.
Most of them in like the past year or
so.
Um
and the the other one nice thing about
these approaches is that what these
papers all kind of do is now, as I
mentioned, you have like this really
good text to image model, stable
diffusion, or maybe uh
at meta they trained like like some some
other team has trained a really good
text image model, or at Google someone
some team has trained a really good one.
Um then they can use those weights to
like really speed up their own training
for video. At least because they they
they they don't have to learn just raw
text image generation from scratch.
Um
This I kind of talked about before. So,
you have your single frame and then you
can encode
each frame of your video.
And then in in in your unit here, so
this is in the unit, you have like your
2D columns, spatial attention applied to
each frame.
And then the only missing thing missing
here to model video is uh you can add
some like temporal layers. You can add a
1D convolution over time. You can add a
3D convolution over space and time. Um
and then
you can insert attention layers. So,
attention over only the temporal axis,
you can do uh full attention over like
all space-time, which is
maybe more expensive, but it could be
useful.
And um optionally, some papers do this,
some papers don't, is you can then
freeze your uh your spatial parameters
to kind of retain
retain like the uh
the image quality. Because I guess one
thing for these generations is usually
like
uh
the the the quality of images and the
quality of individual frames are like
kind of different. Like the the
distributions are a little bit
different.
Um so, if you want to preserve more of
like the high quality like image
generation capabilities
uh to have that carry on to generate
like high quality frames, then sometimes
people will just freeze the parameters.
Or else you occasionally see some sort
of like some sort of like like
degradation. The other The other option
is if you also jointly train, which is
very common if you train from scratch.
You jointly train both on images and
videos, uh which is
quite uh important sometimes.
Um
But yeah, but you can
So, so the way Emu Video works is very
similar
to what I described. Um
the only difference is that they do some
extra factorization where they first
generate the image. So, they generate
the first frame and then you have a
separate model that generates
uh the rest of the frames, like seven or
15 frames conditioned on the first
frame, and then they output FPS, and
then they had temporal upsampling to 16
FPS.
They have some masking to account for
like
what frames are conditioned. So, it's
like if the first frame is conditioned
on, then um
you apply information saying, "Oh, that
this is actually not noise." Um that's
part of your mask.
And then also when you compute the
losses, you actually don't compute a
loss on the first frame. You only
compute on the other frames.
So, these are what some of the videos
look like. Still still kind of like
short videos. So, this is up like maybe
4 seconds. Um
but yeah, definitely
I guess this is an improvement over some
prior works, like for Imagine video, um
Align Your Latents, stuff like that.
Pretty good motion and
pretty good like visual fidelity.
Okay. So, aside from
um
So, I guess if if you can So, if you
want to use like the text-to-image
model, and you can use your per-frame
latents, it like it works, but it's a
little bit a little bit hacky, and it's
not ideal because the way that you're
let like the way that you're encoding
like temporal compression just by
lowering the FPS means that you need
like another model to to upsample the
frame rate. Um
which is not ideal, and then you also
have to choose like
how low a frame rate do I want to be.
Um
So, the other option here that has been
more popular recently
um is basically spatial temporal in
spaces. So, not only So, now So, Stable
Diffusion has a VAE that compresses over
time per image. Uh so why not just train
like a new VAE or a new autoencoder that
just compresses over space and time
simultaneously?
So there were some pretty old works. Uh
something I worked on a while back with
Video GPT.
Uh Tats was another work that was a
follow-up. Both of those were training
like 3D CNN VQ VAEs, VQ GANs.
Uh and then the
and then you use like an autoregressive
model to learn the videos.
Um LVDM here is very similar, um but for
like a diffusion model. So they train a
3D CNN VAE and then they learn the
diffusion prior.
Um
And then for yourself, for one example
is if you had your
your your video with like 256 by 256
images, 16 frames, then you can just uh
kind of it's it's like basically the
same the same architecture as like a
like a CNN over images, but you just
replace like the 2D convs with 3D convs
or you replace like some downsampling
with downsampling over space and time.
You just have to control over like how
much you downsample over space and how
much you downsample over time. So for
example here, it's like you downsample
over space a lot more. So it's you
downsample by factor of 16. Uh for time,
you downsample by factor of four. This
mostly comes with like
I guess a lot of experimentation with
the different downsampling factors. Um
and highly depends on certain things
like the frame rate. So for example, if
I if I double the frame rate of the
video, then I can probably downsample by
another factor of two or something.
Because there's just a lot more
redundant frames.
The the one the one issue, I guess, is
that
which kind of alludes to what I
mentioned before, is that um
it's not exactly like there are ways
around it, but it's not exactly obvious
how you would also want it jointly train
on images. Because when we're training
these, so we're now we're learning a new
latent space for these videos. So it's
kind of hard to take advantage of like a
pre-trained text image model. So, you
have to train this uh this like video
generation model from scratch.
Um and then when you do this, you would
also want to like
almost definitely train on both videos
and images at the same time. Um
one of the reasons why you want to do
this is because
uh
Well, I guess one, there's a lot more
image data available. And and let's say
if your model can process like trains on
like
one 32-frame video,
then that can either be one of 32 frame
frame video, or it could be 32 images.
Um so, kind of with the same amount of
training time, you can see a lot like
significantly more images than you would
like individual videos. And that's kind
of nice because the images are now
independent instead of having like your
frames being like highly correlated. So,
you you you get better images. You you
get better gradients. You you see like
more images. You see like a lot
diversity in like text-to-image
alignment. And then usually there's a
lot more diverse text-to-image data than
actual like text-to-video data in some
cases because text-to-video data is like
a little bit more harder to collect.
So, there there might be some like style
things that you want to be able to like
transfer over. Like if you want I want
to generate the video like a video of a
dog running around in the style of like
like a watercolor painting. There there
might not be that kind of like
text-to-video data, but you can pretty
easily probably find like um
like a text-to-image example of like a
watercolor painting or something.
So, you you you kind of want that
transfer, too.
And uh so, but with a 3D autoencoders,
since it's downsampled temporally,
then it's not obvious since the image is
just like a single time step frame. So,
it's like it doesn't really fit well
with the architecture if it's
downsampling over time because there is
because if it's like if you downsample
by a factor of four over time and your
image is like it's like a video with one
frame, how exactly would you even
downsample that over time? It's not
obvious.
So,
the one kind of way that people have
done it
uh that seems to kind of work is that
you just
design your architecture so you encode
the first frame as just the first frame
and then you encode the rest of the
video frames
uh with like your standard temporal down
sampling.
So, you have weird video shapes now. So,
you have like let's say like a 16 by 256
by 256 or 17 by 256 by 256. Then, you
would input your first frame
into a into a latent that's a 1 by 16 by
16.
And then, the rest of the 16 frames
would be encoded in like a temporal down
sampling manner
which is 4 by 16 by 16. Then, your
entire latent would be something like 5
by 16 by 16.
Um this was used in like Funaki in like
the Magvit series.
Video poet.
Uh Walt pretty wide variety. I guess in
this class we didn't really talk about
Maskgit prior.
It's kind of like a discrete diffusion
thing. Not exactly.
Um
for and then like auto aggressive models
people have explored using these methods
and also for Walt is is like a
diffusion.
Yeah.
That's right. Yeah. Like my question is
like how a batch look like so if you
actually mix video and images and I
imagine like video have also temporal
encoding.
Uh this is training the like the video
generation model or the auto encoder
part?
Yeah, no. This is video generation.
Yeah, so it's um
it largely depends on your architecture.
So, let's say um
so so let's say
uh
I guess people do also shuffling, right?
So, like what does it mean?
Yeah, I mean one way you could do it is
let's say if your downstream model is a
transformer you could just like pack
things together. So, like let's say in
one of your batches it could be um
uh like the video tokens, and then the
other batch could be just packed image
tokens.
And then um
you you need to be careful about what
you attend to. So, maybe you only attend
within each image
that's like packed, and then you compute
your losses like per image.
Uh that's like a pretty common way of
like you basically just uh like you just
you just pack your frames, and you treat
the
like instead of you have like a full
video, or you have like a full video,
but each frame is like a separate image.
And they And they just have to make sure
that there's no like cross-image
computation. You just have to mask
things out in the computation. With
attention, you just mask attention,
which is probably the most common way.
Yeah. Why is it necessary to add
one um cuz I imagine you can just treat
the first one
as the first image, and then have the
other three, let's say if you have four,
right? Have the other three be like why
do you need an extra
Um I'd say it's odd.
Because like I guess if this was like uh
well, if the info was let's say 16
frames,
then you would have like your first
frame, and then you'd have 15 frames
left over.
Um
which does you can't downsample by
factor four
cleanly.
Um
Does that answer your question? I'm not
sure if I
fully understood.
Still trying to understand
why it makes sense. Like how is the
first one different from the rest, I
guess?
So, the the first one I guess doesn't
doesn't go through any like the temporal
downsampling parts of the network.
And the the rest of it does.
Yeah, cuz they represent different
things. The one is one frame, the four
is like 16 frames.
Okay.
This was from Funaki. So, this was like
similar call I guess like uh in the same
time span like concurrent work as
Imagine video, like a year and a half
ish back.
This is like a What is it?
Astronaut riding on a horse.
Um in a sunset or like something like
that.
Um
This is from Walt, more more recently,
like three three months ago, four months
ago.
This was a diffusion model, but able to
generate a lot
a lot more consistent video after like a
year and a half to two years.
And uh
less less artifacts.
And this was another kind of recent one.
There's There's a lot of papers in the
past like few months. Uh from Video
Poet. This is an an autoregressive model
that I think I showed in like one of our
first lectures
of different samples.
This one they interestingly chose like a
like a phone like a like a vertical
resolution,
which is not that common.
Kind of interesting.
Um
The one thing that is interesting to
talk about
um
for for Video Poet and for some of the
papers in which they learn latent spaces
is that So, I guess you all trained like
VVQVA's in in homeworks. So, you know
how that works in in terms of the VQ.
Um there's been more of a shift in terms
of not using VQ
and switching to a different kind of uh
discrete autoencoder
uh called LFQ or FSQ, both
concurrent works.
Um
So, this is more specifically FSQ, but
they work extremely similarly. And the
intuition here is actually it's actually
much more simpler than VQ. So, VQ on the
right here, you have a a codebook that
you index into. So, your your encoder
outputs a vector, if it does like a
nearest neighbors look up of the encoder
and then uh encodes that as a discrete
index.
Uh for FSQ,
these are much more similar to like the
VAEs, I guess. You you like a
low-dimensional
uh embedding space, and then the way you
quantize is is you you basically just
round. So, so you somehow This is like a
like a unit cube
in like some sort of like D-dimensional
space.
Um
and then the way it's quantized
is you just define like these these
bins, like those points
in like this D-dimensional hypercube,
and then you just round to the nearest
bin.
So, what would this look like in
practice in in terms of how you code it
is like you you squash your
representation to like -1 1, and then if
it's like
eight or nine bins that are like you
uniformly spaced from -1 1, and you just
you just round
to that nearest bin.
Uh and that's all it is.
Um
The the gradients are still probably
using straight-through estimator like
for VQ,
um but in practice
this is like much more simpler to it's
like simpler to implement. You you you
don't have that annoying like you VQ
loss for the embeddings. Um and
I haven't really seen When I've used it,
I haven't really seen any like codebook
collapse that you might see during VQ
training.
Uh and it seems to work a lot better.
The one The one not other like actually
nice factor, aside from like stability
and
that stuff, is that
with with VQ
um
So, here is is different metrics, so
like the reconstruction quality on the
top left,
uh sampling
sampling quality of like a downstream
generative model that you train on these
discrete codes, is that with VQ, what
you observe is that as you on the
x-axis, as you increase the the codebook
size,
so this is from like the max is like 2
to the 16,
um like 64K,
uh you actually start seeing like uh
degradation in performance. So, it
starts getting worse. It's like a It's
like a weird U-shape um for both
reconstruction and for um
for downstream sampling.
Uh versus if you for these F S Q L F Q
style methods, you can
at least it doesn't seem it seems to be
steadily decreasing. So, you get better
and better reconstruction with more
codes, and then you get uh better
samples.
Mhm.
Yeah, it uses the straight through
estimator. So, it's like you the encoder
and then you round and then you decode.
And there's a straight through through
that.
Um so, yeah. So, the method is like most
VQ methods trained with maybe codebook
sizes of 16K, 32K. Some of the more
recent, like for video poet that uses
this autoencoder, they trained their
codebook size was like 260K.
So, significantly larger.
Yeah.
Um
pretty high usage. Like for training,
you can get up to like 70, 80% codebook
usage.
So, it's like it actually has a very
high coverage. Yeah.
It might be I think part of the reason
why it's easier to predict is that the
way it's constructed is like
semi-factorized.
So, um
if you have like 260K total codes, you
can break it up into like separate
codebooks of like size eight. Like you
have eight like codebook sizes eight,
codebook size of eight, codebook size of
eight. And that in total is like eight
times eight times eight like unique
combinations.
Which is uh
is that five 512?
Um
So, those are like the 512 codes you
have, but it's broken down into like
three discrete latents of like eight
codebooks each.
No, no. This is this other rounding.
Yeah.
Uh
You you you you you scale it to
something from like zero to eight and
then you just round.
Yeah.
Yeah, so we would care about
quantization. Yeah, or if you want to do
some sort of like
discrete generative model. So, whether
it's using an auto-regressive model or
like
For this Yeah, for diffusion model you
can train this exact model but just not
have the quantization. But then it'd be
very similar to like a VAE function.
Yeah. I guess the only difference is
that you have the tanh squashing.
Okay. So, next section is really brief
on how to improve video generation
models. Because there's been a lot of
like
there's been a lot of works. People have
tried a lot of random things of like of
like doing different super resolution in
time and space and
um
the different like length data,
different resolutions of data, stuff
like that. And I think these are still
probably the key
main main axes or or even the type of
generative model. It's like diffusion
model, auto-regressive model, mask it.
Um
But in the end, I think these are like
kind of the three key axes of which you
can probably
is like is like the most like long-term
improvement.
Um
some of them are kind of straight
forward. So, the first two are are kind
of
in line with each other. So,
as we all kind of know,
uh scale is like just really useful in
these larger It happens like train on
larger and larger models.
If you want If you want to perform
better, the easiest thing to do is just
to train a larger model.
Um
Semi-related to that is just
representation. How can you learn more
compressed latent spaces? So, So can
think of the the like something that is
kind of compressed is the latent space
of like per frame encodings
using like a image V,
more compressed than that would be a
like a 3D VQV or a 3D autoencoder of
some sort that compresses over space and
time.
Um
but in terms of design space for how
these representations are learned and
and how these latent spaces are learned,
I think there's a lot of room for
improvement.
Um but very related to the first one
because the ideal is like the more
compressed your latent space is
than the larger the model you can train
because the
the the more efficient like the because
like yeah, the more efficiently you can
model the data, the larger you can
actually scale up given like a fixed
compute budget.
And the other I think is also
equally if not
perhaps more important
to some extent is just uh
better data. There's like
from from everyone I've like talked to
in industry and or people at startups or
whatever, it's like
there's like so much
like your your model can be better and
better. There's almost no limit to how
good your model can be if you just keep
working on data.
Essentially. Yeah. So when you say
better data here, is it just
more video, longer videos, more labels?
Yeah, I'll I'll go into that.
Okay. Yeah. Um
yeah, one way to think about it is that
the data is the model essentially.
I think in in the limit of like more and
more compute uh the exact type of
architecture or even general model if
you can scale to that much, whether you
use diffusion or auto aggressive, I
think it's like you'll end up getting
like a similar model if you train on
exactly the same data or perhaps with
the same training process.
You know, no exact evidence to support
that but it seems to be the impression
that people have been having that
that uh
the the data is what pretty much mostly
determines your model
conditioned on like some fixed amount of
compute.
And
And so I guess what exactly does this
look like? What kind of videos, what
kind of data do we actually want? So, a
lot of this work
if you're interested, I think uh Stable
Video Diffusion has goes into pretty
detail about what they did.
Um but there's different like axes of
what constitutes maybe good data. You
want good motion, so you want a lot like
dynamic stuff in your video. You want
things moving. It's not very interesting
if like you're modeling a video of like
a person doing a PowerPoint slide.
Um or like someone just standing still,
a person just like talking for 2 hours
in like a Zoom call, you know?
Um
usually using like something like
optical flow.
Uh other one is if you happen to have
So, this may or may not
So, if you happen to have text video
pairs, so text data
um because video data by itself is very
easy to scrape.
Like you can just crawl YouTube or you
can crawl some other like video hosting
site or something.
Uh but you might not necessarily could
get like guaranteed good text labels.
But if you do happen to have it, then
you can do some sort of like clip-based
filtering.
Um and the other axis is kind of like
quality. It's kind of hard to measure.
Um but easiest one is maybe resolution.
There are people that have like
aesthetic scoring models that they
trained. I guess where they curated like
specific data sets where they deem
something aesthetic and then they they
train a model to like output a score for
that.
Um and then there's also other auxiliary
metadata you can have like likes and
views, stuff like that. Um
because ideally it's like if a video has
been viewed a lot or people like it a
lot, it's probably a good quality video
to some extent. It It depends on what
your downstream use case would be.
Yeah.
So, as far as aesthetics go, this seems
like another approach like for LLMs at
least is like RLHF that makes the output
closer to
what we might want. Uh so, have people
tried doing something like with RLHF
with
these like video generation models or
Not No nothing nothing public.
So, I don't really have for image
generation. There's been studies for
that for image generation.
Not sure about for videos. I haven't
seen anything.
Um and yeah, so the the other aspect
that's been getting a lot of traction
recently there's been like a few papers
on is as I mentioned it's really easy to
scrape video data from the web but you
don't have text labels and also maybe
those labels aren't good. Even for like
if you have it from like Lion 5B like
those labels are not that great. So, the
solution is just to synthetically
annotate the data using like a VLM.
These VLMs have been getting pretty good
in terms of like captioning
capabilities.
Um you can use easiest you can use like
for stable video diffusion they use some
off-the-shelf ones they use I think Coca
and they used uh some other video
captioner
um
and they had like an LLM like summarize
and combine those two captions into like
a single video caption.
Um
The other way that they did for like
DALL-E 3 that I think
She's the next slide. Oh, yeah.
Uh I think Tim will briefly talk about
this as well.
Um
they just uh generated or they they just
they just curated a lot of high-quality
captions maybe that people wrote and
then they trained them they fine-tuned a
VLM off of that and then
um they captioned like their their data
set with these captions. So, you can see
um all text is the original text.
I forgot what SS is. I think SS was
using like a very simple captioner and
then with their dense one
uh it's like a lot more detailed.
This channel relies on like a pretty
good base model that you fine-tune or
else potentially you might experience a
lot of hallucination where like the
captions contain information or contain
like words that words or objects that
don't actually correlate with the
original image or video
uh which would then bleed into your
downstream video generation model where
it may start uh like hallucinating
certain things that you didn't want to
do.
Yeah, uh Stable Video Diffusion here,
they basically use purely synthetically
labeled data set of like
150 million text-video pairs, so seems
to work pretty well. And there have been
some other like works that I've seen for
text-to-image generation where it
actually, if you use these synthetically
labeled data, it it's actually ends up
being just better
than the original captions. Based for
from LAION, they're like pretty bad
usually.
So, I guess to answer some question, the
other part about this data is that
good quality data can also be like very
high, like if you want to train a very
good text-to-image, text-to-video model,
another aspect would be very very high
like text-to-video correspondence.
Um
imagine if you had like a 1-minute video
and then you had a caption of like a dog
running around the grass versus a
caption that goes into like excruciating
detail of like
maybe how the camera pans or how the dog
moves, what objects, like what what
color they are, what objects they
interact with, stuff like that
um would actually be ideal because then
you can just feed it to the the
downstream like video generation model
and it can learn all those
correspondences.
Um and the last aspect here, kind of
related data, is it's been shown to be
very effective if you also just
you curate a really small set of like,
you know, 1,000, 10,000 images or videos
of like extre- extremely high quality.
It's like this is like you you filter
like like 10 million images down to like
10,000 or something
uh using some heuristics or or some ways
of
or some like metrics to measure that.
Um
and then you can fine-tune your model
and it actually can make like a really
big difference.
Okay.
So, the last part that I'll be talking
about is different applications.
So, the first one is
video generation models as physical
simulators,
which goes pretty far back in time.
So, this was originally pretty popular
idea, I guess, in robotics
back in like 2016-ish,
2017.
Um in the context Yeah, so robotics. So,
that is like
a pretty common on on the the the the
videos of like a robot arm moving and
pushing objects. It's actually what was
one of like the most common like
video generation benchmarks that was
used
like in the past like few years. It's
kind of like the CIFAR-10 for like video
generation. Um then there was like
games, like Ataris down there. Um
there's self-driving. So, these are some
of like the original video data sets.
Mainly the self-driving one from Kitty
City and then the robotics one.
It's probably the the bare robot pushing
data set.
Yeah. So, I guess the intuition here was
that
if you can predict like
the motion of how the car moves or how
the the robots interact with the
objects, then you can learn a lot about
the the physics of interaction and
potentially use that for different use
cases, like
for planning and stuff.
It was fun on paper in 2016.
Uh
at this point with the video generation
models were like pretty bad. These are
like I I wouldn't even call them like
generative in a sense because they're
kind of like they're trained using MSE
loss and they're like conditioned on
robot actions. So, it's like a fairly
deterministic prediction. Like if if you
say I want to move the arm a little bit
to the left, then
it's like pretty deterministic in terms
of what the outcome is. So, there's not
that much randomness. Um but you just
want to model and see if you can
actually like if I if I push this arm
into like a into a into like a a ball,
the ball will maybe feel that force and
maybe it'll roll like across the bin,
something like that. Um
these are just some examples of how they
of like fairly low resolution
results that they use for for downstream
planning.
Yeah.
For sure.
Um
So, in the end, it will model only what
is in your data. So, if your data does
not contain crashing cars, it will not
model that.
So, um
So, in general
Uh if it had a lot of crashing cars,
yes.
Yeah. If it had like one instance, I
maybe not. Yeah.
Um
Yep.
Oh, yeah. I'll I'll I'll go over some
some concrete examples. Or or sorry,
even how they're actually used in
downstream situations or
They're usually used as like visual
planners. So, it generates like a visual
plan of like I I guess uh is an example
here. So, like if if you you can prompt
it with like the first like the first
image, let's say it's ground truth, and
then this this text-to-video model you
can say, "Oh, place
place the hand above the blue cube." And
then it will do a generation of the the
the robot doing that.
And then you can use that resulting
generation uh to to then um
So, I don't Okay, I don't have it right
now. Um
I think it's another paper where you can
use that general like you can use that
generation and also like what people
call like an inverse dynamics model,
where they they take two adjacent frames
and they compute the the the robot
action that was taken.
Uh and then you can do that for every
adjacent frame, and that will produce
like a trajectory for the robot motion
that you can then do to try to replicate
the the plan that was generated.
So, your question here?
Okay. I had a question about like
how close is that to the generated video
to the one that the
the model that has been trained on? Um
I guess in this case, I mean there are
In these cases, it's usually pretty
good, but it depends. Yeah. For example,
for the rocket one that you showed
before,
is there some kind of I guess there is
also some kind of robot in the training
data? There's a The real the real
question is like is there like some GAN
similarities as we have seen
for uh
the GAN, you know, like the image
generated by GAN and then you look for
the same
the closest in the training set. Have
people done also videos?
Um
not super common.
Yeah, people stopped doing that for some
reason.
Um
but for these cases,
usually they're examining like uh
downstream videos that are like
I wouldn't say out of distribution, but
the like like locations of blocks that
are usually not in the training set
or something like that.
Or same thing for videos. You usually
for like a lot of scale text to video
models, I wouldn't worry about too much
about
like um
just like like memorizing a video and
like
and outputting that. Unless like you
really messed up the like the the
pipeline of the the video data.
We can likely memorize a video.
Well, if if if the video is present like
like 20 times in the data set, it could
memorize it.
Yeah, it's possible. If there are a lot
of like duplicates of certain things.
But if for any I I'd say that for any
problem that appears in text to image
generation, it could also appear in text
to video generation.
Or even from language.
This is another example of like how you
can condition different actions. Uh you
can close the middle drawer. So, this is
all generated video just conditioned on
different successive text prompts. You
can open the drawer, grab the water
bottle,
stuff like that.
It's like some sort of like physical
interaction through the text.
This is another example from some
from Wave where they trained a uh
They trained on like text uh What is it?
They they trained on
like self-driving data video data.
So, this is all generated video.
Which you can kind of tell if you really
squint or oops.
But yeah.
So, it was able to like do things like
oh, it knows it's supposed to stop when
a car is in front of it.
Um you can do turning.
You can like change I think it was
almost going to change lanes. But yeah.
Do do different times of day, stuff like
that.
Yeah.
Um kind of similar to the one I showed
before of like where you can ask it to
open and close the drawer, you can
prompt with different text. So, this is
also trained on like a lot of other data
like language data
of actions um
and and videos and then you can do a
driving simulator and and turn in
different directions.
So, I guess if you ask it to turn left
when it's already close to the curb, it
might like veer into the curb.
But, not not exactly crash. So, it's
still kind of biased towards the
distribution. Kind of to answer a prior
question is like if you ask it to turn
left there, it's not going to go onto
the curb. It's probably not going to
because all the data was probably
generally like good driving like like a
good driver. Not not going to do crazy
things like crashing into things,
driving off, you know, running into
people and stuff like that. So, it's
probably not going to do that either.
Uh oh, this is just the model. They just
have different modalities. They have
like the the video frames, the actions,
which I think is like the steering
wheel, and they have different like I
guess they have like text descriptions
of certain things happening. They just
train on all of that. Um just on like a
concatenated
auto aggressive model in this case.
Nothing too crazy.
This was recently from Covariant which
they released their uh robot model,
which part of it they had a lot of
capabilities, but part of it was video
generation. The
bottom left one here is a generated
video.
And then the bottom right was the actual
traject- the actual like resulting um
like
the the actual motion for ground truth.
And then top left was like let's say
like some like conditioning information
or top left and top right. Like what
object to pick up um
and to put it where.
Yeah, this was trained on all sorts of
only I guess for the the the simulator
part, the most relevant one is the video
prediction. Um but they it was next
token token prediction on like the bunch
of different modalities of like
language, images, um different kinds of
robot data, stuff like that.
Um
One other example of how the plan is
actually explicitly used for for visual
planning, which I think I mentioned I
kind of briefly talked about before.
Where I you should go do like something
like like visual MPC, where you have you
can kind of like simulate rollouts and
simulate different actions. So, these
are like action conditioned. So, you
condition on robot action to generate a
prediction for its frames, and then it
basically does like kind of like a a
search, I guess,
um
to find the action trajectory that that
moves it most towards like the goal.
And in this case, the left frame is the
initial frame, the middle one is like
the
the goal, I believe, and then the last
one, or that's like the final trajectory
of like the actual real robot running
it.
And then below here is different like
simulations of of what it think uh
it like what it thinks it might be
doing. What are the actual interactions?
Um this is the one I mentioned where the
inverse dynamics model, so you generate
the plan of a task being completed, and
then you apply inverse dynamics to every
neighboring frame
to to output robot actions per time
step, and then you can
uh and then you can execute them on the
actual robot to hopefully
have it perform that task.
Um
the last one is some work we also did on
our lab. Um
You you can use the video generated as
long as you have a likelihood based
video model, you can use it as
a reward essentially just by using the
likelihood. So, you can have it mimic uh
certain So, like if if if if your if
your video model was trained on like
certain tasks as of like of picking up
like the saucepan of the lid of the
saucepan, um then high likelihood areas
or high likelihood transitions would be
transitions that um
make it
like
imitate the same activity. Um
So, you can use it as a reward for for
downstream reinforcement learning.
Um
And it it works decently well.
Okay.
Um and the last one is or the last
section I'll be talking about is just on
video editing. So, that's the other main
application that I think people are
interested in.
Um
which probably started off mostly with
images. So, a lot of these works will be
a lot a lot of the works in video
editing will be like, "Oh,
uh
we were able to do this. We were able to
use like a diffusion model like an image
diffusion model to do image editing, and
the extension to doing something similar
to video for videos is like kind of
straightforward depending on like the
edit that you want to do."
Um some of these are not restricted to
diffusion models. Like for ControlNet,
uh most of it is diffusion, but the
actual downstream generative model
doesn't matter. Um
and the way ControlNet works, if you've
heard of it, is essentially you're just
augmenting a pre-trained generative
model or a pre-trained image or video
generation model
uh with extra conditioning capability.
So, let's say I want to generate an
image conditioned on like the like the
Canny edge map or something or on a
depth map or on a human pose, something
like that.
And the way this is done is there's many
ways to do it actually, but for
ControlNet, the way they do it is they
just have like two copies of the model.
So, on the left or on like the
the the the right most um
the right most figure, the left side is
let's say standard stable diffusion.
And then the right side is
that's in blue is like extra parameters,
where they basically um
where there's like extra like trainable
parameters that's a copy of the the same
block that's frozen.
And then
that accepts in the conditioning
information. So, usually the
conditioning information for this case
is the same the same shape as the image.
So, if it's like a edge map or like a
depth map, it's like the same uh
resolution as the original image and
then you can feed it through the network
and then condition on those features
um for your your frozen models.
And
so the whole thing is trained assuming
you have some sort of like paired data.
You have like
I mean some of it's easy. Like if you if
you want to make like if you want to
condition like a grayscale version, you
can just convert the color image to
grayscale and that's pretty easy to
convert paired data for depth. You can
maybe apply a depth estimator
um
for some of these you can usually just
run a model to to to compute that data.
And this is kind of what it looks like.
So this is for images. So for the
the the top is I guess an example of
that conditioning information. So
sketches
normal maps, depth maps, canny they're
different kinds of edge detections uh
segmentations that would just be you you
input as like RGB. Uh human pose is
pretty popular. There's like a lot of
things that
you make characters want to do different
dances or something.
Um and yeah, so the generation basically
it just takes into account all of the
conditioning information and it aligns
with that
but everything else usually just like
the color or something is like
randomized or like the textures like
randomized and you'll see things that
are different.
And you can do the exact same thing for
video. There's like no reason you can't.
You just take the
3D U-Net and you add conditioning in the
same way.
Um but just in this case your
conditioning information is is like a
video and it's like a
posed video of people dancing. So I So
the left is the
uh I think what the pose was computed
from and then the right is you can
condition on the or the the most right
you can condition on
the human pose in the middle and then
like a text prompt. So the text prompt
is like some
I forgot. It's like some
business person in a suit in like 1800s
London or something.
Uh and then you can do depth as well
there.
That was I think the text prompt was
like the style.
So like some sort of a animation style
or something.
So this is fundamentally just like you
can you can choose a condition on every
anything as long as you have the data or
you have the pair of data to to train it
on.
Uh this is more for
This is I think the changing the hair
color. And then
from daytime to nighttime.
Some things are not preserved that you
like for example the the top the the top
row the prompt was just mainly to change
the hair color to red, but you can also
see it change like the
uh
You can see a leak out. There's like the
the walls that are connected to the
window are different color. One is like
more brownish on the the original is
more brownish and then the other one is
like more reddish.
Another way is um
called SD edit. It's pretty simple. This
is like more specific to diffusion
models.
Um
but the way this is done is that
you
I- Intuitively is as you apply the
diffusion forward process
you noise and noise and noise your image
more.
Um
and then uh
and then you can reverse it with like
with the new text prompt that you you
you edit.
So
the the way it kind of works here is
like
is like you you have like So in this
case you have like your your your like
your your stroke image which is that
input.
And then as you noise and noise and
noise the the the distribution of that
image gets gets larger and larger cuz
you're adding more and more Gaussian
noise.
Um and then the same thing if you also
noise let's say like a like a target
image. You You don't exactly know what
it is, but you apply more and more
noise, you also see the the the
distribution expand expand. And the
intuition here is that as as these both
expand more and more,
they will overlap eventually somewhere.
And then so once you've applied enough
noise, you can then apply the reverse
SDE with like a new text prompt. So if
you have this as input, and then maybe
the the new the new text prompt you have
is like a a realistic image or a
high-definition image of
What is that? It's something.
Um
then it it it will sample
um
it will denoise, but now denoise in a
different direction towards like your
desired target image.
So this is the actual process of kind of
what I described. So you you you have
like separate text conditioning, so you
have your
uh your image, and then you have, let's
say, an edit caption. So you can apply
the forward process
to your your image, so you apply like
some amount of noise. The the amount of
noise you apply is actually is a
hyperparameter.
Uh so that's something that you can
tune. The more noise you add, the more
information from the original image you
destroy.
Um and that the less noise you add, the
the more it retains fidelity, but the
less that it can it can like change
stuff.
Um
And yeah, and then so once you have your
noise image, you can then apply the
reverse process with a new with a new
caption prompt.
Um that I kind of went over already.
Um
so this is an example.
So you you you can you can imagine for
for videos, this is you can just take up
any pre-trained text-to-video model. Uh
You you can you can have like this this
bear, you can apply noise to it, and
then you can sample it back out
uh with a new prompt, like a bear
dancing made of wooden blocks.
And then so you can see some of the
coarse information is preserved, like
the general shape of the bear,
um and also the the the of the bear.
Um
because as you're noising it, you're
probably having noise out all of like
the brown color. It's probably still
there. Yeah.
Um,
what does stroke mean?
Uh, oh, that that was from like way back
when like it's like a sec- it's it's
like you can imagine like
um,
I think they have this capability in
some like maybe Photoshop or something
where you can instead of drawing instead
of an artist drawing the full image,
they can just draw like um,
they can just like do like
color blobs to represent different
things
and from that to render the the original
to render like a more realistic image.
Okay. And and so that's what the authors
are sort of proposing as the novelty.
They're like using that in the diffusion
process. Uh, no, the the the novelty is
this is this editing process. It's like
I mean it's very simple. You just apply
noise
and then you sample back out with a with
a new prompt. So, the new prompt will
usually reflect something different than
what was in the original image. Uh, oh,
okay. I I get Okay. So, just adding like
the dependency on that caption that they
sent. Yeah.
Yeah.
And how do they use the text to guide
the diffusion? Do they use like the
words and all that?
It's a standard diffusion sampling with
like like CFG or something with with
like yeah, the standard guidance.
Yeah. Are we applying Gaussian in
pixel space or latent space?
Um, pixel space. Uh, well, it depends on
the model, I guess. So, if if if the
model is a pixel diffusion model, it'd
be in pixel space. If it's a latent
diffusion model, it'd be in latent
space. So, will it will it work both
ways? Mhm.
Yeah.
Yeah. So, you get Yeah, these kinds of
edits. You can make things into Legos.
So, yeah. So, like depending on how much
noise you add, you can have the back-
some of the background can be like
destroyed. So, you'll see some of the
background there like all white now.
There's no horizon.
The what the road is kind of gone. I
mean, it's just a blob now.
Um so it's like a hyper parameter that
you can tune.
Yes.
It is the same. Like the intuition is
like you're after you've corrupted it
enough, add enough Gaussian noise, then
uh
that that that noise is now a
um
so so now the resulting sample from that
noise, if you apply the reverse process
back, there's a lot of different images,
right? There's a huge like it it's not
only your original image that was in
that is a possible solution. There's now
a bunch of images that are possible
solutions.
Okay, so so basically the addition of
this new text text input does not
change. No.
No no yeah, the intuition is all the
same.
Yeah.
On the topic of generalizability in this
situation, it seems maybe less apparent
here, but from the last one, is the
source video you're they're using
generated from the same diffusion model
or is that like an actual test video?
It it looks very like
I'm not sure. It it it works on real
videos, though. Okay, I see.
Yeah, this is unclear. Yeah.
Um okay, and the last paper I'll be
talking about is Quad Remics. Kind of
supports more general video editing.
Um
So, the the way
the way this works, I mean, I guess in
its simplest terms is um
you have like a pre-trained like video
like text to video diffusion model and
then um
you can apply an SDE style an SDE style
thing. But, that kind of like limits it
towards like general broader style
changes.
Um
you're still retaining a lot of the
structure of the video. So, it's like
what happens if you also want to edit
like the motion of the video? I have a I
have a video of like
Shoot, I'm an example here.
I have like a video of a monkey on in
water and then you want to make it uh
wave its hand.
Something like that. So, so something
like SDE edit wouldn't really work
because it preserves all the coarse
motion or coarse information in the
video.
Um
So, yeah, we need a different approach
for this.
And the way this works is very similar
to if you're familiar with like
DreamBooth style things. Essentially,
you can fine-tune. So,
you you you can essentially fine-tune on
a single video. So, you fine-tune this
entire like pre-trained text to video
diffusion model on this one desired
video that you want to edit. So, kind of
expensive because you have to do this
fine-tuning every time.
Um
but you yeah, you fine-tune with the
video and then you can have like a rare
token, which they also have used in like
Dream DreamBooth style, called T star.
It it could be just any It's just like
this rare token. It's just any token
that is not very commonly used in in
like in language. You can just like do
like a a count. You can just go through
like a
potentially like a bunch of captions or
like a large like natural language like
corpus and just like count the frequency
of each token
as it appears in the in the text and
then take some tokens that are extremely
infrequently used. So sometimes it's
like if you decode them out, they're
like just really random things.
Um
But you you you you you can just treat
this as like a a token that you feed
into like a caption. So instead of like
So when you're fine-tuning and it's like
a video of a monkey, instead of
fine-tuning with that caption, you would
do like a video of a a monkey a monkey
or a video of like T-star.
So that will hopefully capture like
kind of when it sees that token, it'll
know oh, we're talking about this
specific video or of this specific
monkey or or entity or whatever.
And the fine-tuning loss here is just
the diffusion loss. So you you you just
ask it to
to but you denoise it as like this one
single video. So it's like batch size
one training for like 50 100 iterations
um on the single video that you
fine-tune this model on.
There there are some other design
choices here where they not only did I
not only do you fine-tune on on videos,
you can also fine-tune on individual
frames or or or like individual images
or or mix mix of images. Um in those
cases, it's the same, but you can just
like fast mask out any temporal
operations in the network here on the
right.
Basically like an attention mask or
something.
Which I'll show an example of why this
this could be useful for some things
they did.
Uh
yeah, fine-tuning loss The final
fine-tuning loss they did was just the
video diffusion loss and then another
like video diffusion loss, but with the
temporal things masked out.
Which support like per-frame stuff.
So some examples of what they did. So
left is the input video. I think these
are real videos. So these are not
generated Or I mean, these would be
pretty good generated videos if they
were.
Um the right is the generated video
of like slicing a cake. Kind of
interesting because it does like the
kind of the physics do kind of change
here.
Like slicing the cake is a lot more like
resistant potentially, I guess, compared
to cutting through a fruit.
So, the knife kind of slows down there
and um
kind of like sticks to the knife.
So, this is where the image fine-tuning
loss kind of comes in. They just
fine-tune you can just treat as a
concatenating like
seven images of uh
different viewpoints of the same action
figure and then um
you can prompt it with this edit
caption. So, in practice, it wouldn't be
like a toy fireman, it's probably like
AT star where like your unique token is
lifting weights.
Um this is pretty neat. You can kind of
Yeah, it's it's a toy fireman lifting
weights, so.
This is the monkey one that I showed.
Kind of works, but there's some like
oversaturation in terms of like the
result. Not exactly sure why.
Yeah.
Um
and then there's also some trade-off
between like
potentially like how much noise like
during sampling, how much noise you add
and like how much you fine-tune. The
longer you fine-tune, the more it it
starts fitting to the original video on
the right column.
And then noise is kind of like SD edit
noise, so the more noise you add, the
more information
uh is corrupted, so it can change the
background more. If you add very small
amount of noise, then all the
fine-grained details are still there, so
when it samples, it's still like a grass
in like a river or whatever. Um but if
you add more noise, then
some of the core structure is retained,
like the position of the monkey, but
it's now sitting in a different
environment. And if you add too much, it
basically just generates a different uh
video. I think the caption here was like
an orangutan in a bathtub or something.
Yes. When we do editing, can we edit
like out of the really long videos?
Uh that depends on the method whether it
would support that. For this one, no,
because you have to fine-tune. It will
support max It will support just like
the the training distribution length.
But, some sometimes, depending on the
method that's developed, it can extend
to longer videos.
Uh, the last one
that you can do with the fusion models
um
is also do video inpainting. This was
from
Lumiere
where you can crop out or like mask out
certain parts of the model
and then prompt it with something
different. So, you have your original
video on the left, and then the second
one is like wearing a bathrobe or
something.
You have to tune the mask like the
masking region for each one, depending
on what you want to change. But, you can
insert different objects. It's wearing
like a party hat or something, or it's
like standing on like a wooden stool.
Cool.
Yep, that's pretty much it.
Um